hey you recognize the woman and man
behind the beauty mask it's Dax Shepard
and Kristen Bell deck captain the moment
I drank Kristen's cool eh let's see
where this goes
he also wanted you to know that it is
indeed his wife and not Jason Vorhees
just clarify proposed to have so much
fun together Kristen and Dax will
celebrate their fifth wedding
anniversary this October and as only Cal
teen I found out they have a fond and
messy memory of how they verse made
recently Kristen kind of explained how
you guys first got together in this text
message that went on is it true who
knows her memories the work okay she
said that you asked for the gum in her
mouth and then later texted her hi my
name is Dax I violated your privacy and
got your number from Shawna how do you
feel about that yeah that checks out but
but to be very clear I didn't say hey
can I have the gum in your mouth he said
hey do you have any more gum and you
said I don't have gone only this made
this and then he took it out of my head
that is true yes but he asked for gum I
said no I didn't have any then I pulled
it out and said only this and then he
took it was like I'll take half out of
your mouth and then I did it's been love
ever since yeah darn near they shared
already chewed gum and a love for lip
synching Africa while in Africa
[Music]
he calls Kristin a hashtag mom shell and
proudly tells everyone he loves her even
though she wears gloves in the swimming
pool
have you tried it I haven't tried it so
you're absolutely right it may be the
best way to swim another thing these two
share is a passion for activism Kristin
fights against childhood hunger and
right now Dax is shooting a special PSA
September is prostate cancer awareness
month the premise of this spot is what
would you rather do than do that and so
we will explore the many things that I
would rather do I'd rather sit in the
middle seat on a long haul I'd rather do
hot yoga next to a sanitation worker
come straight from work always you know
I was smart I had this whole system
because when I had a vasectomy cheers
ladies I was knocked out and then the
doctor said would you like me to do all
of the things that you know need doing
down there I said do it all
[Music]
[Applause]